Ve geldik mutlak değerli fonksiyonlara.
Güzel arkadaşım, bir tarafta mutlak
değer bilgimiz, diğer tarafta doğrusal
fonksiyon bilgimiz. Bunları bir
birleştireceğiz. Bir de muhteşem
taktiklerle, bunlarla ilgili bütün nitel
özellikleri, grafik özelliklerini
hepsini birlikte halledeceğiz. Ve bu
derste bittiğinde şunu diyeceksin. Hocam
ben mutlak değer fonksiyonunu çok iyi
öğrendim. Hedefimiz bu. Eğer sen o
tarafta hazırsan hemen modül 2'yi
alıyorsun eline. Sayfa kaçlara geldik
hocam? Şöyle bir bakıyorum. Hay maşallah
diyorum. 40'lara kadar gelmişiz. Sayfa
42'yi açıyorsun. Bugün ders biraz uzun
olacak. 42'yi beraber bitireceğiz. 43'ü
beraber bitireceğiz. 44'ü beraber
bitireceğiz. Sonraki ders için de artık
hazırlıklarımı yapsam. Şimdi ben bu
tarafta hazırım. Sen o tarafta eğer
hazırsan elimizde kalemler, önümüzde
kitaplar, bir tarafta sen, bir tarafta
ben. RM olarak gönder, gönder gelsin
hocam dedeyim. Fonksiyonlarda normalde
11. dersimizdeyiz ama bu mutlak değerli
fonksiyonların ilk dersi. Güzel
arkadaşım. Şimdi ben sana mutlak değerin
tanımını anlatacağım. Hocam biz tanımını
biliyoruz. Mutlak değerin ne anlama
geldiğini biliyoruz deme. O
bildiklerinin hepsini bir kenara bırak.
O ön yargıların hepsini bir kenara
bırak. Çünkü mutlak değerin tanımını
doğru bir şekilde bilmez. Uygulayamazsan
mutlak değerli fonksiyonu da
anlamlandıramazsın. Hazır mıyız? Gerçek
sayılarda. Şimdi gerçek sayılarda neye
bakacağız biz artık? g(x) fonksiyonuna.
Nedir bu g(x) fonksiyonu? İster mutlak
içerisinde x olsun ister önünde eksi
mutlak içerisinde x olsun. Bu biçimdeki
mutlak değer fonksiyonların bütün nitel
özelliklerini öğrenmeye çalışacağız. Ama
ne dedim? Önce mutlak değerin tanımını
bilmen lazım. Ya hocam işte mutlak değer
her şeyi dışarıya pozitif çıkaran işte
bu cümle en büyük hatalardan biridir.
Senin en büyük hata yapma sebeplerinden
biridir. Belki de mutlak değeri
öğrenemem sebebendir. Mutlak değer sayı
doğrusundaki bir sayının 0a olan
uzaklığı demektir. Yani sen bir daha
mutlak değer dediğimde aklına tek bir
şey getireceksin. Uzaklık abi. 0 olan
uzaklıktan bahsediyoruz. Tamam mı?
uzaklık olduğundan mutlak değer sayının
negatif ya da pozitif olmasına
bakılmaksızın
her zaman pozitif veya 0 değeri alır
diyeceksin. Neden? Çünkü sen benim
evimin bizim eve pardon yani bizim evin
okula olan uzaklığı 500 metre der misin?
Dersin ama -300 met demezsin. O yüzden
hiçbir şekilde bakmıyorsun pozitif ya da
negatif olmasına. Diyorsun ki bizim evin
okula olan uzaklığı ya 300'dür ya 0'dır
ya da bizim ev okuldur gibi bir şey
oluyor gerçi o ama yani en azından her
zaman 0 veya pozitif değerler alır
diyoruz şimdi. Ama hocam biz de zaten
öyle diyorduk tanımı diyeceksin ama
orada bir düzeltme yapacağız. Şimdi
mutlak değer fonksiyonu nedir? Bak şimdi
mutlak içerisinde x'i vereceğim ben
sana. Mutlak içerisinde x'in anlamı
nedir? Eğer ki x değeri 0'dan eşit ya da
büyükse dışarıya aynen çıkar. Lütfen bu
cümleleri beraber öğrenelim. Beraber
kullanalım bunu. Dışarı nasıl çıkarmış?
İçerisi pozitif ya da 0sa aynen çıkar.
Hocam eğer ki mutlak değer içerisindeki
ifade negatifse yani bak bilmiyorum
içeride bir şeyler var böyle a + b - c
terimli bir şeyler var fark etmez.
İçerisi negatifse işlemi yaptım, baktım
içerisi negatif çıkıyor. Dışarı nasıl
çıkar? Önüne eksi alarak çıkar. Ya da
biz onu daha güzel bir tabirle
söyleyelim. İşaret değiştirir. İşaret
değiştir. Bütün olay, bütün mevzu bu.
Şimdi mutlak değerli fonksiyonu bu
şekilde görünce hocam bu da doğru değil
mi anlamında bazen kavramlar çıkıyor. X
> 0 o zaman dışarı aynen çıkar. x 0'a
eşit ya da 0'dan küçük olunca önüne eksi
alarak çıkar. Burada 0'ı nereye dahil
ettiğinin bir önemi yok. Çünkü 0 önüne
eksi de yazsan, artı da yazsan nötrdür.
O fark etmez. O yüzden ister eksi tarafa
ekle ister 0'ı pozitif tarafa ekle.
Burada yaptığımız gibi. Ama biz kendi
aramızda yapmışız bunu. Bir anlaşma
yapalım. Diyelim ki arkadaş bundan sonra
biz 0'ı pozitif tarafa ekleyelim. Hani
bir daha acaba negatife mi ekleyeyim,
0'a mı ekleyeyim diye karmaşaya
düşmeyelim. Bu kendimizce bir kabul
olsun. Tamam mı? işleri kolaylaştırmak
için. Güzel. Şimdi mutlak değerini
anlama gel. Hatta şunu bile söyleyenler
olacaktır. Hocam mutlak değerli
fonksiyonu bazen böyle de çıkartıyoruz
ama x > 0 isa dışarı aynen çıkar. X eğer
0'a eşitse dışarı 0 diye çıkar. Eğer ki
x 0'dan küçükse dışarı nasıl çıkar?
İşaret değiştiri çıkar. Ama ben ne
diyorum ısrarla? Benim kullanacağım
mutlak değer tanımı bu. Bak, girizgah
biraz uzun olmuş olabilir ama konuyu
öğretici girizgah budur. Şimdi bir tane
mutlak değer sorusu çözeceğim. Hemen
fonksiyonuna geçmiyorum direkt. Bir
kargo şirketi merkez deposundaki uzaklık
esas alınarak farklı dağıtım noktalarına
malzeme taşıyormuş. Bu şirket merkez
depoyu M noktası. Şimdi merkemiz merkez
neresi? M noktası. Farklı şubeleri de şu
harfler olarak belirlemiş. Her şube
merkezin bulunduğu noktaya olan uzaklığı
ölçülmüştür. Zaten şu uzaklık kavramını
gördüm. Konu olarak aklıma direkt ne
gelmeli? Mutlak değer gelmeli. Güzel.
Hedef belli. Merkez depoluyla bıdıb bıdı
şubelerinin doğrusal bir hat üzerinde
olduğu biliniyor. Süper. Doğrusal
olduğunu da biliyoruz. Bak bu
doğrusallıkta örneğin merkez şube
burası. Tamam mı? Herkesin buna göre
uzaklığına bakacağız. M noktası merkez
depo olarak 0 noktasıdır. Aa sayı
doğrusu gibi oldu. Tam da benim
istediğim mutlak değer tanımına uyuyor.
0a olan uzaklık kısaca bak A ve B
noktaları sırasıyla 4 birim ve 2 birim
merkezin solunda sırasıyla 4 birim ve 2
birim. Şimdi 4 birim uzaklıkta bulunan
kim? A. O zaman A burada şuradan şurası
4 birim. 2 birim uzaklıkta bulunan kim?
B. O zaman B burada arkadaş. Devam
ettim. CD, E noktaları ise sırasıyla 3
1, 5 birim merkezin sağında. 5 birim
merkezin sağında bulunan kim? E noktası
şurası arkadaş. Buradan burası 5
birimmiş. Yazdım. Sırasıyla dediği için
D noktası 1 birim uzaklıkta. D noktası
şuradaymış. Buradan burası 1 birim
uzaklıkta. C noktası 3 birim uzaklıkta.
Hadi burası da C noktası olsun. Şurası
da 3 birim uzaklıktaymış. Tüm bu
verilenlere göre şubelerin merkeze olan
uzaklıkları sayısal olarak belirleyiniz.
Şubelerin konumlarını gösteren tabloyu
doldurunuz. Arkadaş şimdi şubenin
merkeze olan uzaklığı artık negatif
ifade edilebilir mi? Mümkün değil.
Negatif ifade edemezsin. Bunu ne yapmak
zorundasın? Ya pozitif ya 0 olarak ifade
edeceğiz. Örneğin A noktası. A noktası
normalde sayı doğrusunda aslında kaça
tekabül ediyor? -4'e tekabül ediyor.
Yani sayı doğrusundaki konumu a'nın
nedir? -4'tür. Ama merkeze olan uzaklığı
nedir? + 4'tür. Aslında özünde yaptığın
şey sen uzaklık kavramı dediğin an
Türkçe karşılığı şudur. Yaptığın işlemin
-4'ün 0a olan uzaklığı kaç birimdir
diyorsun? 4 birimdir. Ben az önce ulan
uzaklığı mı dedim ya? Olan uzaklığı
olacak o. Yeni kalktık. Sesim de daha
yeni yeni açılıyor. Geldim B'ye. B
noktası aslında sayı doğrusunda nerede
çizdim? -2'de çizdim. E benden aslında
B'nin -2'de olduğunu söylüyor ama mutlak
değerce -2'nin anlamı neydi? + 2'ydi.
Hocam geldim C noktasına. C noktasının
merkeze olan uzaklığı ya da sayı
doğrusunda nerede? + 3'te. Aslında
benden istediği merkeze olan uzaklığı da
yine + 3'tür. Zaten sayım pozitifti.
Onda değişen bir şey olmadı. D noktasına
geldim. Merkeze olan uzaklığı 1di.
Aslında bunun da anlamı sayı doğrusunda
+ 1'e tekabül ediyor. Mutlak değerce
1'in anlamı da yine nedir? 1'dir. Aynı
şekilde geldim. E noktası aslında sayı
doğrusunda x = 5'e tekabül ediyor. E
mutlak değerce 5 demek merkeze olan
uzaklığı 0 olan uzaklığı demek o da 5
demektir. Olay mevzu galiba anlaşıldı
arkadaşım. Şimdi yola devam ediyoruz.
Bak burada B seçeneğimiz var. Şuradan
bir okuyalım. Bir şubenin konumu
bağımsız değişken yani x merkeze olan
uzaklığı ise bağımlı değişken olsun.
Tablodaki değerlerden yararlanarak
bağımlı değişkenin x cinsinden cebirsel
gösterimini yapınız. Şimdi benden şunu
istiyor. Diyor ki kardeşim diyor ben
sana diyor bağımsız değişkeni verdim. X
uzaklıklar olsun. Sen bunu bir fonksiyon
şeklinde bana göstermeye çalış. Mesela
buradaki değerleri alalım. Ne var
elimizde? -4 var. -2 var. Ondan
sonracıma 1 3 5 var. 1 3 5 var. Her
birinde ayrı ayrı sonucu az önce buldum.
Şimdi bu bağımsız değişken -4 olduğunda
cevap ne oldu? +4. -2 olduğunda + 2.
Kısaca aslında ben buradan buraya
geçerken hep neyi aldım? X'in mutlını
aldım. Soruda benden özellikle şunu
vurguluyor. Ben diyor bunu bir fonksiyon
olarak yazmak istiyorum. Uzaklığını
bağımlı değişken olsun. Tablodaki
değerlerden de yararlanarak bağımlı
değişkenin x cinsinden cebirsel ifadesi.
X cinsinden cebirsel ifadesi ne
olacaktır? mutlak içerisindeki
x olacaktır. Burası tamam mı? Bak daha
tam olarak fonksiyon yok aslında. Hatta
buradaki fx'i de silebilirim. Mlak x'i
yazarsam çok daha şık olacak. Güzel.
Cebirsel olarak böyle gösterilir hocam.
Şimdi geldim bağımlı ve bağımsız
değişkenler arasındaki bu değişkiyi
gerçek sayılarda tanımlı bir fonksiyon
olarak ifade edip grafiğini çiziniz.
İşte geldik bombanın patladığı noktaya.
Arkadaş bağımlı ve bağımsız değişken
bana bir de neresini veriyor? tanım
kümesini veriyor. Sen bir fonksiyonun
tanım kümesini verdiğin andan itibaren
olay bitmiştir. Ben diyelim ki bu
fonksiyonun adına fonksiyonu diyeyim.
Gerçek sayılarda tanımlı demek ne demek?
R'den R'ye tanımlı demekti. Biz bunu
doğrusal fonksiyonların başında
anlatmıştık. Şimdi geldim. f(x)'in
kuralı ne olacak? Bağımlı değişkenim
artık mlak x ile gösterilmesi gerekiyor.
Süper. Artık bu şekilde gösterilecek.
Ben yine tablodan yararlanayım. Tablodan
faydalanıp grafiğini beraber çizelim.
İlk defa mutlak x'in grafiğini
çizeceğiz. Hazırlan. Şimdi ne
yapıyordum? Ben buradan değerler
veriyordum. Mesela -2, -1, 0, 1, 2
şeklinde değerler veriyordum. Şurası +
2, burası + 1, burası 0, burası +1,
burası + 2 olacak. Doğru mudur? Hemen
geldim. Koordinat düzlemini çizdim. Bu
koordinat düzleminde tek yapmam gereken
noktaları yerine yazmak. Doğru mudur?
Yazalım bakalım. Hocam, x'i diyor sen -2
alacaksın, -1 alacaksın, +1 alacaksın, +
2 alacaksın. -2 aldığında cevap nereye
gidecek? + 2'ye gidecek. O zaman şöyle
mi çizmemiz doğru olur? Bak şuradan bir
nokta aldım. Bunu çizdim. -1'e 1'i çiz
diyor. -1'e + 1'i çizdim. Tamamdır. 0a
0'ı işaretle diyor. İşaretledim. + 1'e
+1'i işaretle diyor. +1'e +1 noktasını
işaretledim. + 2'ye + 2 noktasını
işaretliyor. Onu da işaretledim. Şimdi
bu noktaları birleştirme vakti. Hocam
noktalarım buradan buraya geliyor. Evet
geldi. Ardından bu tarafa doğru kırılıp
bu tarafa doğru gitti. Elde ettiğim
fonksiyonun grafiği kimdir? f(x)
fonksiyonunun grafiğidir. Bu da mutlak
içerisinde x'in grafiğidir. Mükemmel
hocam. Zaten zor değildi. Çizerdik biz
bunu diyorsun ama burada önemli olan
nokta ne biliyor musun? Hemen doğrusal
referans fonksiyonuyla bunu
karşılaştırmak. Hocam normal şartlarda
yeşille çizdiğim fonksiyon nedir?
doğrusal referans fonksiyonudur. Bak, y
= x'in grafiğidir. Anlaştık mı?
Anlaştık. Peki, y = x ile sadece mutlak
koyduğumda fonksiyonun neye uğradığını
bir tespit edelim mi hocam? Fonksiyon
geliyor. Geliyor buraya kadar. Yani x'in
pozitif olan taraflarında değişen bir
şey var mı? Yok. Zaten burada bir
sıkıntı olmadı. Aşikar. Ne zaman ki x'in
sol tarafına geçtiğimde yani y ekseninin
soluna geçtiğimde yani x'e negatif
değerler vermeye başladığımda aşağıdan
değil de artık fonksiyonum x eksenine
göre sanki simetriye uğruyor. Normalde
-1'e nereden geçmem lazımdı? -1'den.
Normalde -2'ye nereden geçmem lazımdı?
-2'den. Ama tam tersine nereye
gidiyorum? Yukarıya gidiyorum. Bak bu
noktaları da şöyle göstermekte fayda
var. Bu nokta buraya taşınıyor. Bu nokta
buraya taşınıyor. Her bir noktayı
aslında x eksenine göre yukarı
kaplıyorum. Bunu şöyle hayal
edebilirsin. Hocam bak şimdi ne
yapıyoruz? Şurada x ekseni geçtiğini
Allah ben tam ekran yaptım sanıyorum. x
ekseni tam şuradan geçtiğini düşün.
Buradaki doğru parçasını ne yapıyorum
aslında? Tam ters yukarıya doğru
katlıyorum. O katlama işlemi sonucunda
yukarıya geçtiğini hayal et. Güzel.
Buraya kadar galiba oturuyor mevzu
aslında. Özünde benim yaptığım şey ne
biliyor musun? Biz f(x) = mlak x'i sanki
parçalı fonksiyon grafiği gibi çizmedik
mi? X0'dan büyükse y = x'in grafiğini
çizdik. x 0'dan küçükse -x'in grafiğini
çizdik. İnanmıyorum aslında. Benim
yaptığım bak grafiğimi bir daha
çiziyorum. Baştan sona bir daha
çiziyorum. İzle beni. Hocam ilk gelen
grafik aslında kimin grafiğidir? y =
x'in grafiğidir. Nereye kadar hocam? Bak
0 da dahil olmak üzere buraya kadar y =
x'i getiriyorsun. Sonra devam eden
grafik kimin grafiğidir? Bunların
hepsini detaylı da öğrenmiştik zaten.
Hatırla. y = -x'in grafiğidir. Burada en
net cümle ve asla unutmaman gereken
cümle. Benimle birlikte yazar mısın bir
noktaya? Şuraya bir yere yazıyoruz
arkadaş.
Her mutlak değerli fonksiyon her mutlak
değerli fonksiyon mutlak değerli
fonksiyon fonksiyon aynı zamanda aynı
zamanda nasıl fonksiyondur? Parçalı
fonksiyondur. Parçalı fonksiyondur.
Fonksiyondur.
Süper. Yani biz mutlak değerli
fonksiyonları nasıl yazabiliriz hocam?
Parçalı fonksiyon şeklinde yazabiliriz.
E parçalı fonksiyon şeklinde yazdığımda
da oluşan grafik kimin grafiğini
verecek? mutlak değerli fonksiyonun
grafiğini verecek. Ama biz uzun uzun ya
hocam bunu parçalıya ayıralım bir parça
böyle bir parça böyle çizmeye gerek var
mı? Gerek yok. Neden? Mutlak değerli
fonksiyon asla yani bir uzaklık kavramı
asla negatif değerler alamıyordu, değil
mi? Alamadığı için bizim negatif değer
alan bölgemiz burası. Buranın altında
kalan parçayı nereye taşıyorsun?
Yukarıya taşıyorsun. Olayı bitiriyorsun.
Şimdi gel hocam. hx = ek - mlak
içerisinde x fonksiyonun grafiğini aynı
koordinat düzleminde çizerek
karşılaştırın diyor. Biz ama yine ne
yapmak zorundayız? Nereden nereye
tanımla hocam? Tanım kümesi olmazsa
çizemezsin. Reel sayılardan reel
sayılara. Aynı şekilde hx'in kuralı ne
olacak bu sefer? Eksi mutlak içerisinde
x olacak. E ben işleri kolaylaştırmak
istiyorum sana. Ne yapmaya çalışacağım?
Tabii ki önce şunu yapacağım. Bak mutlak
içerisinde x'i bulacağım. Ardından eksi
mutlak içerisinde x'i bulacağım. Yine
değerler verelim. -2, -1, 0, 1, 2
değerlerini verdik. Tamam mı? Peki -2
verdiğimde + 2, -1 verdiğimde +1 0 1
2'yi elde ederim. Fakat geldiğimde önüne
eksi koy diyor. -2, -1, 0, -1, -2. Elde
edilir mi? Elde edilir. Şimdi ne
yapacağız hocam? Yine gel. Allah,
kaydırdım aşağı doğru. Yine geldim.
Grafiğimi çizeceğim. Normalde grafiğimi
çizmek için ne yapıyorduk? Noktaları
birleştiriyorduk. Hızlıca noktaları
birleştiriyorum. Bak -2'de neredeyim
hocam? -2'deyim. Şurası -1 olsun. Şurası
-2 olsun. -1. Şurası -2 olsun. Şurası
+1. Şurası + 2 olsun. -2'de neredeyiz
hocam? -2'deyiz. Geldim işaretledim.
-1'de neredeyiz hocam? -1'deyiz. Geldim
işaretledim. 0da 0dayız. + 1'de
neredeyiz hocam? Bak +1'de neredeyim?
-1'e geldim. 2'ye neredeyim hocam?
-2'deyim. 2 verdiğimde de cevap beni
nereye götürdü? -2'ye gösterd götürdü.
Şimdi tek yapmam gereken artık bu
noktaları birleştirmek. Noktaları
birleştirdiğimde kimin grafiğine ulaşmış
olacağız? H = HX = - mlak içerisinde
x'in grafiğine ulaşacağız. Aynı yere
şunun grafiğini de çizelim mi hocam? Az
önce çizdiğimiz grafik kimin grafiğiydi?
Şu mutlak içerisinde x'in grafiğiydi.
Buna da hadi g(x) fonksiyonu adı
verelim. Ya da biz f demişiz. f diyelim.
Yine f(x) fonksiyonu adını verelim.
Mutlak içerisinde x. Bunlar arasındaki
tek fark nedir? Bunlar arasındaki tek
fark sen eğer bu mutlak içerisinde x'in
grafiğini çizdiysen eğer ki ulaşmak
istediğin o x'in mutlak içerisinde x'in
önüne eksi koymuşum. Bütün değerleri
negatif yapmışım. Eskiden herkes
pozitifti. değer demek y tarafında
pozitif şeyler almak demektir. E artık
hepsi negatif olacağı için burayı
katlanma çizgisi olarak düşün kağıtta.
Çat aşağı doğru bunları ne yaptım?
Katladım. Demek ki ben mlak x'in
grafiğini bulduğumda bana o önüne eksi
koyduklarında o ifadenin grafiğini
çizmemi istediklerinde tek yapmam
gereken x eksenine göre simetri almak.
Anlaştık mı? Bak buradan buraya geçerken
ne yaptık? X eksenine göre simetri
aldık. Simetri aldık. Anlaştık. Hocam
peki mutlakın grafiğini çizerken ne
yapıyorduk? Çok özür hocam. Normalde
mutlak değer yokmuş gibi çiziyorum. Bu
kimin grafiğiydi? y = x'in. X ekseninin
altında kalan parçasını x eksenine göre
simetri alarak yukarı taşıyorduk. Niye
böyle yapmıştık? Çünkü asla negatif
değerler almıyorduk. Bak buradaki
değerler negatif. Bunları birebir yukarı
taşıyorduk. Müthiş ya. İnanılmaz kolay.
Sadece mantığını oturtman lazım. Şimdi
her zaman yaptığımız gibi bu nitel
özellikleri de birlikte dolduralım.
Nedir bu nitel özellikler? Önce doğrusal
referans fonksiyonunun en geniş tanım
kümesine bütün reel sayılar. g(x) mutlak
içerisinde x tanım kümesi diyor. Tanım
kümesi demek x'lerde alabildiğin
değerler demek. Bak hadi yeşil için
konuşuyorum aslında. Bütün x değerlerini
verebiliyor muyum? Verebiliyorum. O
zaman bunun da tanım kümesi ne olur?
Reel sayılar. Eksi de koysan önüne reel
sayılar. Biz zaten tanım kümesini ne
aldığımızı buradan bilebiliyoruz. Burada
buna g fonksiyonu demiş. Ben kafalar
karışmasın diye aşağıda gel biz de ona g
fonksiyonu diyelim. Biz buna f diyerek
başlamıştık mevzuya ama her yerde ona g
yazalım da kafaları karıştırmayalım.
Hani hangi fonksiyonu aldığımızda belli
olsun. Anlaştık mı? Bu arada illa onun g
olması gerekiyor diye bir tabir bir
kural yok. Bil. Görüntü kümesi. Görüntü
kümesi. Biz y ekseninde karşılık ne
yapabiliriz? Y = x'te bütün değerleri
alabiliriz. Bütün reel sayıları
alabiliriz. İşte zurnanın zart dediği,
zurt dediği yere geldik. Mutlak
içerisinde x. Gördün hocam. Y eksenine
karşılık gelen değerler. Bak grafiğim
geliyor geri dönüyor. 0'a kadar geliyor
en aşağıda y ekseninde ama artı sonsuza
kadar gidiyor. İşte bombanın patladığı
yer. 0dan artı sonsuza kadar değerler
alabilir. 0ı alabilir. Peki mutlak
içerisinde - x'in alabildiği değerleri
söyler misin? Dikkat et. O da 0'dan
başlıyor. Y ekseninde karşılık gelen
değerler neresi? Eksi sonsuza kadar
gidiyor. Tabii eksi sonsuz daha küçük
sayı olduğu için eksi sonsuzdan nereye
kadar geldik? 0'a kadar. Görüntü kümesi
dediğinde y eksenine bakıyordun hatırla.
Tanım kümesi dediğinde grafiğin x
ekseninde taradığı bölgeye bakıyordun.
Fonksiyonun 0ı x eksenini kestiği
noktaydı. Bu tanımları bilmezsen
yapamazsın. Ben hep ne diyorum?
Matematik zeka işi değil. İstediğin
kadar zeki ol. Fonksiyonun 0ı. Abi
tanımını bilmiyorsan nasıl yapacaksın?
İşte o yüzden fonksiyonun 0ı dediğimde
tanımına bakacağız. Tanım ne diyor? X
eksenini kestiği yer. y = x doğrusu.
Yani doğrusal referans fonksiyonu. X'i
nerede keser? 0da keser. Mutlak
içerisinde x 0da keser. Önüne eksi de
koysan 0da keser. Dikkat ettiysen her
seferinde ne yapıyorum? X eksenini 0da
kesip devam ediyorum. Bütün
fonksiyonlarımda maksimum noktası. Hocam
ne diyorduk? Doğrusal referans
fonksiyonunun maksimum noktası yoktur.
Neden? Doğrusal referans fonksiyonu
negatif değerlerden başlar. Artı sonsuza
kadar gider. Geldim. Mutlak içerisinde
x. Bak kritik yerlerdeyiz. Mutlak
içerisinde x. Bu maksimum noktası var
mı? Yani y'de durduğu bir yer var mı?
Yok. Artı sonsuza kadar gidiyor. Yani
bununla bir maksimum noktası yoktur. E
hocam bunu sen söyle. Mutlak içerisinde
x ama önünde eksi var. Bak geliyor
geliyor geliyor. Y ekseninde çarpıyor
geri dönüyor. Y'de geldiği maksimum yer
neresi? 0dır. Mükemmel bir bilgi.
Ezberlemeyeceksin bunları. Bunlar
ezberlenmez. Bunlar ezberlensin diye
sana verilmiyor. Grafiği çizdiğinde
yorumlayabilesin diye. Şimdi seninle
birlikte yorumluyoruz. Minimum noktası.
Doğrusal referans fonksiyonunun y
ekseninde en dip noktası var mı? Yoktur.
O zaman minimum noktası da yoktur.
Geldim ama mutlak içerisinde x'in
minimum noktası var mı? Y'de geldiğimiz
en dip nokta burası. Bak en aşağı
burası. 0'dan başlıyorum yukarı doğru
çıkıyorum. Demek ki daha aşağı
inmiyorum. Demek ki minimum noktam var.
0a 0 nokta dediği için tabii bunu
koordinat olarak yazmak zorundayım.
Maksimum değer deseydi 0, nokta dediği
için 0'a 0. Minimum noktası 0a 0. Peki
mutlak içerisinde - x'in minimum noktası
var mı? Aşağı iniyorum. İniyorum
iniyorum. İniyorum iniyorum. Sonsuza
kadar inebiliyorum. Hayır. Bir minimum
değeri, bir minimum noktası bunun da
nedir? Yoktur. Birebirlik. İşte kritik
yerlerden biri daha. Hocam sadece yeşil
grafiğe bakar mısın? Birebirlik neydi?
Yatay doğru kesiyorsun. Bir noktada
kesiyorsa ne diyorduk? Hop fonksiyon
bire birdir. Geldim. Mutlak içerisinde
x'e yani yeşil grafiğe. Ben yatay doğru
çektiğim andan itibaren hatta gel bunu
sarıyla çekelim. Çektiğim andan itibaren
ne yaptım? İki farklı noktada kestim.
İki farklı noktada, 3 farklı noktada, 4
farklı noktada birden fazla noktada
kesiyorsan kısaca birebir değildir. Bak
bu fonksiyon birebir değil. Aynı şekilde
çok kolay oldu hocam. Mutlak içerisinde
-x yatay doğru mu çektim? Farklı iki
noktada kestim ama hocam buradan
çekseydin tek noktada keserdin. Evet
orada tek noktada keserim ama bütün
yatay doğruları kontrol etmek
zorundayım. Bir tanesi bile iki farklı
noktada kesiyorsa şunu söyleyeceksin.
Hocam bu fonksiyon bire bir değildir.
Bir tane bile farklı nokta yani birden
fazla noktada kesiyorsan bire bir değil.
Artan veya azalan olduğu aralıkları
yazınız diyor. İşte burada da yine
kritik yerlerdeyiz. Bu fonksiyon yani
şey doğrusal referans fonksiyonu sürekli
yukarı doğru gitmiyor mu? y= x
fonksiyonu sürekli nasıl bir
fonksiyondur? artan bir fonksiyondur.
Peki bunun artan veya azalan olduğu
aralığı yazarken sürekli artan fonksiyon
yazacağız değil mi? Sürekli artan
fonksiyon. Peki hangi aralıkta artan?
Eksi sonsuzdan artı sonsuza kadar artan
bir fonksiyondur. Geldim. Mutlak
içerisinde x'e bak. Kritik yer. Yeşil
grafiğe bakıyorsun. Nereden? X'in
hizasından başlıyorum. Eksi sonsuzdan
geldim. Geldim. Geldim. Geldim. Geldim.
Geldim. 0'a kadar. 0'a kadar. Bu
fonksiyonun değeri hep ne oldu?
azaldı. Demek ki bu fonksiyonun azalan
olduğu bir aralık var. Bir de ne olduğu
bir aralık var. Muhtemelen artan olduğu
bir aralık var. Ayrı ayrı yazıyorum.
Nereden gelmiştim az önce gelirken? Eksi
sonsuzun hizasından geldim. Nereye
kadar? 0'a kadar. Yazalım. Eksi
sonsuzdan 0a kadar azalan bir grafik
çizdim. Hocam niye sen burayı kapalı
grafik yaptın? Artanlık, azalanlık bir
aralık kavramıdır. Noktasal bir kavram
değildir. Yani ister açık yap ister
kapalı yap. Aslında ikisi de doğru ama
en geniş olduğu azalan aralık diye
sorulduğunda ki yıllarca MEB'in
kitabında bu hatalı olarak basıldı
arkadaşlar. Hatalı olarak verildi bu
bilgi. Öğretmenler birbir aralasında,
matematikte böyle şeyler çok olur.
İnternette işte Facebook gruplarında
olsun, WhatsApp gruplarında olsun işte
burası açık olacaktı, kapalı olacaktı.
En son noktayı koydular arkadaşlar.
Burası kesinlikle kapalı aralık olmak
zorunda. Çünkü tanım bize çok net
söylüyor. Artanlık, azalanlık bir aralık
kavramıdır. Tek başına 0 noktası
artandır ya da azalandır diyemezsin. Bu
sebeple biz burayı nasıl alıyoruz?
Kapalı aralık arıyoruz. Açık alırsan
hatalama ama değil. Ama şu sorunun
cevabı da değil. En geniş olduğu, azalan
aralığı söyler misin? En geniş olduğu,
azalan olduğu aralık eksonsuzla 0
aralığıdır. O da kapalı aralıdır.
Anlaştık mı? Burası çok ince detay bir
bilgidir ama bilirsen senin için iyi
olur. Derece tayfayı zaten böyle böyle
yetiştirirsin. Şimdi geldim artan olduğu
aralığa. Yine yeşil grafiğime bakıyorum.
0ın hizasından başlıyor. Nereye kadar
gidiyor hocam? Artı sonsuza kadar. Artan
olarak gidiyor. O halde yine 0'ı kapalı
aldım. Artı sonsuza kadar gittim. Neden
0ın kapalı olduğunu söyle sormuyorsun
artık bana değil mi? Ama şu kafana
takılıyor. Hocam 0 artan aralıkta mı
azalan aralıkta mı? Ben de sana yine
aynı şeyle cevap veriyorum. Tanım.
Artanlık, azalanlık noktasal bir kavram
değildir. Aralıkla ifade edilir. O
yüzden tek başına 0'ın artan ya da
azalanlığı diye bir mevzu söz konusu
olamaz. O yüzden iki tarafa da
ekleyebilirim.
Anlaştık mı? Şimdi mutlak içerisinde x
ama önünde eksi vardı. Dikkat et. Bu
bölgede sürekli ne yapıyor bu fonksiyon?
Artıyor. Eksi sonsuzun hizasından
geliyorum. 0'a kadar. Önce azalan yazdım
gerçi ama altına da şurada artan olduğu
aralığı yazalım. Artan olduğu aralık
neresidir? Eksi sonsuz 0 aralığında
artandır. Bak öbür fonksiyonun tam tersi
gibi davranıyor zaten. Geldim 0ın
hizasından artı sonsuzun hizasına kadar
x'e göre cevap verilir. Artanlık
azalanlık. Çünkü tanım bölgesine
bakılır. Ne yapıyoruz? Sürekli azalıyor.
O zaman azalan olduğu azalan olduğu
aralığı ha şimdi yazıyorum. Nereden
başladım? Kapalı 0dan başladım. artı
sonsuz aralığına kadar azalarak devam
ettim. Bu sayfa belki de bütün mutlak
değer fonksiyonunu öğrenmek için yeterli
bir sayfadır. Ama ben boş duracak mıyım?
Hayır. Sana ekstra bilgiler anlatacağım.
Burada önemli bazı mevzulardan
bahsedeceğim. Ya da bu dersi hiç şey
yapmayalım, bölmeyelim. Şöyle bölelim mi
arkadaşlar? Ben size bir ders daha
göndereyim. Mutlak değer fonksiyonuyile
ilgili. Tam buradan bitirelim. Tam
tadında tuzunda yorulmadan ama seri
halde her gün 9. sınıf videoları gelmeye
devam edecek. Dilersen şöyle yapalım.
Bir ders burayı beraber işliyor
olacağız. Şimdilik benden bu kadar. Bir
sonraki derste görüşene kadar kendine
iyi bak. Hoş kal. Hoşça kal. Yalnız
videolara yorum atmayı, beğeni atmayı
unutmayalım. [müzik]
Pho Yeah.